lowe's a fait cette annonce à l'occasion
de la présentation des résultats du
troisième trimestre qui ont été très
bien accueillie par les analystes
l'action a grimpé de 4%
les revenus de lauzes n'ont pratiquement
pas bougé et près de 17 milliards et
demi de dollars américains les ventes
grimpent aux états unis mais elle baisse
au canada
les profits ont bondi de 67% pour
dépasser le milliard de dollars
américains avec nous jacques nantel
professeur émérite à hec montréal
spécialiste du commerce de détail
bonsoir monsieur nantaises ont suffi
est-ce que c'était prévisible ce qui se
passe présentement les scénarios ces
épisodes de fermeture est ce que c'était
prévisible selon vous oui en fait en
grande partie oui et ce pour plusieurs
raisons
lorsque vous avez un géant comme l'os
qui achètent un groupe comme rona c'est
presque un mariage contre nature parce
que l'os est une c'est une
c'est une armée de grande surface
principalement des grandes surfaces
extrêmement bien organisé avec une
logique et une culture corporative
groupe rona c'est un mouvement
associatif le groupe grenoble possédait
plusieurs magasins mais ronan c'était et
c'est toujours d'abord et avant tout un
grossiste la majorité des détaillants
affiliés à rona étaient des indépendants
et surtout de petits indépendants
arriver là dedans lorsque vous êtes losc
c'est une culture qui vous échappe
c'était prévisible qui aurait sûrement
une restructuration écoeurait des
fermetures de magasins
ceux qui ont été annoncés l'an dernier
sur des magasins qui avaient été achetés
au cours des dernières années avant
l'achat c'est le groupe coupât lente
rodez marcil dont on assiste à la
deuxième vague de fermetures oui c'était
prévisible donc est ce qu on serait dans
la même situation si ronan était demeuré
propriétaire propriété québécoise en
on serait peut-être dans la même
situation mais avec sûrement moins de
fermeture je suis pas sûr que les
acquisitions qui ont été faits lors des
dernières années du groupe rona je pense
entre autres les bannières marcel et
coupal auraient été achetées que d'une
part et d'autre part le mode de gestion
était beaucoup plus adapté au type de
réseau que l'on avait est-ce qu'ils
auraient eu des fermetures des coupures
possiblement de rona avait déjà des
difficultés en 2016 quand l'entreprise a
été acquise avec des disques
mais il faut il faut bien comprendre que
lorsque vous regardez puis si vous
retournez aux états financiers de 2016
de metz est une conjoncture qui est très
différente afin de les années qui ont
précédé 2016 notamment après 2008 2009
ça a été des années difficiles pour à
peu près tout le monde mais quand vous
regardez les états financiers de renard
cette époque mais que voulez comparer à
d'autres géants dont entre autres lowe's
home depot
c'est un gros qui fonctionnait quand
même passablement bien à fait ce qui
était intéressant c'est que depuis le
rachat de rona il ya beaucoup de
concurrents de type renault de type
affiliés actifs au québec mais dans le
reste du canada on penchera entre autres
on le mentionnait dans le reportage
bmr un kanak patrick morin qui eux ont
émergé écouter ces trois entreprises là
ont été chercher des parts de marché et
en grande partie aux dépens de rona se
sont emparés des clés du succès passés
de rona pour développer des concepts
semblables et faire concurrence
finalement ronald o clairement
clairement parce que dans ce créneau là
des plus petites surfaces c'est pas tant
la bannière que les personnes qui sont
là qui sont importantes
si vous voulez aller dans une grande
surface home depot fait très très bien
le travail là où également si vous
voulez une plus petite surface est
beaucoup plus le propriétaire opérant
qui joue donc diriez vous que les
insuccès sont surtout attribuables à la
gestion de l'eau aux deux puis trois est
ce que je comprends c'est en fait vos
questions est excellent parce que lowe's
dans les résultats que vous avez
présenté son sont très éloquents
du côté américain ça fonctionne très
bien souvent de des gestionnaires
absolument efficace écoutez les ventes
de l'iphone mais les profits augmentent
donc ça veut dire qu'on est capables de
comprimer les coûts et on gère ça comme
des bons gestionnaires une entreprise en
bourse on s'attend absolument vous
arrivez dans le groupe renault c'est un
peu comme si vous venez d'acheter le
village gaulois c'est pas la même chose
peut pas débarquer à demander un
propriétaire aupérin de changer son mode
de fonctionnement d'acheter davantage et
d'acheter certains types de produits
puissent le propriétaire aupérin vous
vous êtes dans le fond un grossiste à
ses yeux lui
là c'est un mode de gestion qui est très
différent tellement différent que au
cours des dernières années
il ya beaucoup de
franchisé ou d'affilier rona qui se sont
désaffiliés on parle des fermetures ici
mais il ya eu des défilés à sion lieu il
y en eut de l'autre côté également y en
a sur tech se sont affiliés à vonnas
mais la majorité ce sont des affiliés
parce que il ne se retrouvait pas dans
cette structure là ce qui est à prévoir
pour les prochaines années c'est que
l'on doit continuer à imposer son modèle
parce que pour eux et à juste titre best
model qui est plein de succès ce qui
marche aux états unis d'oeuvrer au pays
canada donc une incompréhension tout
avenue incompréhension de la culture du
marché du québec et du canada du reste
du canada également parce que il n'ya
pas qu'au québec où on a ces structures
fédératives va tout est ce qu on a déjà
connu cela dans le passé je vous
entendez parler de l'aube là et de
provigo et quinze années 90 fait tout à
fait en fait c'est pratiquement
exactement le même scénario
lorsque l'eau blaze acheter provigo ils
ont acheté dans une alimentation le
village gaulois c'était tout les petits
dépendant alors que l'aube là ce sont
tous des corporatif qui appartiennent à
l'aube l'as écouter lorsque l'achat
c'est fait le provigo était dominant au
québec en termes de part de marché de
mémoire je pense qu'ils avaient 45 par
pourtant de part de marché ils ont
laissé tomber sol mais de manière
cruelle sachant pas comment récupérer la
donne beaucoup de propriétaires provigo
ont soit fermé été rachetés ou ce sont
des affiliés et aujourd'hui la bannière
noblesse n'existe plus au québec on a
ramené la dernière provigo et je dois
dire je salue cette initiative parce que
ça fonctionne plutôt bien
c'est vraiment une question de
compréhension d'un marché de façon de
faire donc est ce que vous vous nous
annoncez d'autres épisodes difficiles au
québec au canada dans ce mariage entre
l'eau 09 j'aimerais j'aimerais plus
optimiste mais non je pense qu'il va y
en avoir d'autres
parce que la station don laws s'est
implanté ils sont ils se sont implantés
aux cadeaux par l'acquisition d'un
réseau un réseau qui leur ressemble pas
du tout home depot ça a été très
différent ils sont rentrés ils ont
construit chaque magasin ils l'ont
construit oui de la façon dont ils
savaient construire et opérer des
magasins où ce jeudi donc ils ont
implanté leur formule de a à z dès la
première année là c'est parfait
jacques nantel merci beaucoup pour cette
analyse ce soir
c'est bien